Ja Leute, ich bin heute wieder ziemlich im Arsch, aber nichtsdestotrotz, wir hatten jetzt
einen so schönen Streaming Streak, die letzten Tage habe ich gedacht, komm so eineinhalb
Stunden am Abend, das kriegen wir jetzt auch noch gebacken.
Also chat, ich muss sagen, ich dachte nicht, dass dieses E-Mode so gut ankommt und wem
haben wir es zu verdanken?
Ich glaube dem Chainlaw, oder?
Das wird passen, das wird passen, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt
ein Chainlaw E-Mode.
Ich würde jetzt mal von ausgehen, im Zweifelsfall ist es eins.
Soll ich euch mal der letzte Stream freietrag fahren am dritten, sechsten?
Wirklich?
Ich habe jetzt quasi eine Woche fast gestreamt am Stück, guckst, nö, ehrlich gesagt, ich
kann dir auch sagen, warum ich das nicht gucke, weil es gab in den letzten Jahren wenig Triple
A Games, wo ich gesagt habe, boah, da freue ich mich voll drauf und das hätte sich gelohnt
da irgendwas zu gucken.
Ich schaue mir eine Zusammenfassung an, ich weiß nicht wie lange das geht, bis 22 Uhr
oder so glaube, ich schaue mir Zusammenfassung an und wahrscheinlich sind am Ende eh nur
zwei, drei Sachen dabei, die auch ansatzweise spannend sind.
Können wir eine Version mit dem Kix als Sub-E-Mode bekommen?
Ne, das geht nicht, das geht echt nicht.
Erstens, weil ich das E-Mode schon ein bisschen grenzwertig finde und zweitens, weil Twitch
keine anstößigen E-Modes erlaubt.
Das steht sogar extra in den E-Mode-Bedingungen, die man ankreuzen muss, also dass man keine
... Was übrigens auch nicht erlaubt ist, sind die ganzen E-Modes mit Keanu Reeves und sowas,
weil eigentlich darfst du keine E-Modes nehmen mit dem Gesicht von Leuten drauf, also außer
sie sind von Twitch und haben da zugestimmt und sowas, aber ich meine, wie sagt man,
wo kein Kläger ist, da kein... Ach, keine Ahnung, ihr wisst, was ich meine, wahrscheinlich
interessiert es im Endeffekt keinen wirklich.
So, ich muss mal kurz die We Shop oder We Store oder wie auch immer der Kramis Musik ausmachen,
das wird zu aufregend, nicht auf... Der We Shop Channel, genau, ich muss hier irgendwie
eins von meinen Standard-Dingern anmachen, ach komm, ist was... Nein, das wollte ich
jetzt nicht gucken.
Das auch nicht, WTF, warum habe ich hier so viel Zeug aus, ja, Songs and Smiles, sehr
gut.
Moin Erbsenraupe, Bringsich, zeig euch mal was, neue Sophos Firewall einrichten, ja gut,
weil man 20.15, also Primetime, da macht man nur die besten Sachen.
Ich zeig mal schnell was für die Leute, die dabei waren, als wir den EPG-Cham programmiert
haben.
Was gepusht gerade, guckst du Summer Games fest, ne, ich guck mir danach irgendeine Zusammenfassung
an.
Der Desktop, der Desktop ist Massive Pog, ich finde alles, ich habe euch schon oft demonstriert,
dass ich alles finde.
Außerdem ist der Desktop noch nicht voll genug, weil der Explorer bzw. die Startleiste
laggt noch nicht.
Erst, wenn die Startseite anfängt zu laggen, dann weißt du, der Desktop ist zu voll.
Wartet ihr das schonmal, dass der Desktop so voll war, dass wenn ihr Windows-Taste gedrückt
habt, dass die Windows-Taste erst 8 Sekunden später aufging, dazu braucht ihr ungefähr
viermal so viele Icons auf dem Desktop, das habe ich schon geschafft.
Ich finde es fragwürdig, warum die Icons auf dem Desktop überhaupt beeinflussen, wie
schnell das Startmenü aufgeht, aber gut, das ist Microsoft, das darf man nicht weiter
hinterfragen.
Wenn kein Platz mehr in die Icons gesteckt, ne Microsoft kann sowas nicht, die Icons gehen
einfach aus dem Bild raus.
Also wenn du, guck mal ich zeig es dir, also mal angenommen, wir nehmen jetzt hier Pog,
was auch immer Pogu ist, ist das T++ als TXT, ok was auch immer, das ist Pogu, also wenn
ich das jetzt hier weiter einfüge, Pogu, Kopie von Pogu mache, also es laggt schon richtig
Leute, also wenn ich Kopie von Pogu mache, und das mache ich so oft, das hört sich total
bescheuern, also ich mache jetzt mehrere Kopien von Pogu, dann wird das irgendwann leaked,
da ist überhaupt nichts leaked, guck da ist nichts drin, was soll ich denn hier großartig
leaken bitteschön, irgendwas was wir eh schon im Stream gemacht haben, ich mache jetzt ganz
viel Kopie von Pogu, und du wirst sehen, guck mal wie langsam das ist, ich drücke, du wirst
sehen was passiert, es passiert nichts, es geht einfach aus dem Bildschirm raus, also
Microsoft sortiert den Kram einfach weiter hier hinten, die haben da keine Logik drinne,
so jetzt muss ich mal kurz auf meinen Desktop und alle Pogus wieder wegschmeißen.
Pogu deleted, oh was ist denn das hier, Windows XP from Fashion, das kann auch weg, ich brauche
Platz, guckt euch das mal an, ich habe nur noch, ich habe nur noch 11G frei, das geht
aber nicht, ja ich pull mal kurz ganz schnell, bis das Stream so richtig losgeht, ich pull
mal kurz die aktuelle Version vom EPG Champ, übrigens wer sich das angucken will, der nicht
dabei war, hier gibt es das, Moment, EPG Champ auf Github, ich habe es auch alles auf Github
gepusht, bin mir nicht sicher ob ich dieses Wort richtig geschrieben habe, Modularizing,
was auch immer, so ich pull mal kurz, niceissue, keqwe, ja ey dieser Typ, wer auch immer das
gewesen ist, der war der Meinung, er muss mich jebaiten mit einem Recroll Video, wenn man
das anklickt, so ich starte das mal kurz, ich habe mir sogar den Startparameter copy
paste, dass ich das jetzt nicht eintippen muss, ups was mache ich denn, Backend, Start, Rider,
Musik, Toss, warum ist die Musik Toss, oh achso, ich habe meinen NPM install, habe ich vergessen,
zeige euch mal was, ach die vom Issue, die vom Issue, die darf ich nicht abspielen, ja
die ist Toss, so guck mal, ich habe noch eine Sache gemacht, erstens lädt der EPG Champ
jetzt ein bisschen schneller, initial muss er einmal laden, dann backt er ein bisschen
rum, aber wenn ich jetzt nochmal lade, er lädt schneller und, also das schnellste ist
es nicht, so und jetzt passt mal auf, ein bisschen verbackt ist das ganze schon, aber
ok, wenn ich jetzt, ihr seht, es gibt Hover, Hover Effekt, Hover, Hover Effekt und wenn
man hier draufklickt, dann hat man jetzt ein Darkseam Popup und auch eins mit ordentlicher
Schrift und ordentlicher Anzeige, Channel Logo, Record Button, Close Button und man kann
sogar, das geht sogar per Animation auf und zu, guckt euch das an, du kannst Escape drücken
dass das Popup zugeht, sinnvolle Features, ja stell dir vor, ja das wollte ich euch mal
kurz zeigen, Uhrzeit fehlt im Popup, ich habe das Popup neu gemacht, das habe ich noch nicht
eingefügt, die Uhrzeit kommt da auch noch hin, das ist doch schön, das heißt du hast
bald Abschlussprüfung, ja tatsächlich, also mein aktueller Chef ist anscheinend weg,
was ich blöd finde, weil mit dem habe ich mich gut verstanden, ich finde auch der hat
das gut gemacht, warum, keine Ahnung, will ich jetzt hier nichts zu erzählen und kann
man im Endeffekt auch bloß Mutmaßen, aber wir kriegen jemanden neues, das ist wohl
noch die beste Wahl die man treffen konnte für uns, weil alle anderen Alternativen werden
wirklich hochgradig nervig gewesen, aber ich bin eh gespannt was kommt, also ich habe
in einer Woche ungefähr, das weiß man noch nicht, aber das würde ich jetzt hier auch
nicht erzählen, so in einer Woche habe ich dann zum ersten mal Gespräch mit meinem neuen
Chef und dann muss ich den gleich fragen, wie sieht es mit Homeoffice aus, weil ganz
im Ernst, es hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn ich da mit denen jetzt die große Planung mache
und dann kommt am Ende raus, es gibt kein Homeoffice und ich kündige, das wäre ja bescheuer,
also ich muss den gleich fragen, was mit Homeoffice ist und wenn die sagen geht nicht, dann kann
ich bloß nochmal sagen, überlegt euch vielleicht nochmal, weil aus diesen und diesen Gründen
und wenn nicht, dann bin ich weg, du meinst, dass man eine Genreanzeige neben macht, das
Problem ist, die Beschreibung ist ziemlich doof, guck zum Beispiel, ist die, kannst
ja mal schnell zeigen, warte mal, also die Genre Beschreibung ist ziemlich dämlich,
nämlich warte mal, guck mal, die Genre Beschreibungen sind teilweise nicht so kurz, ah ne, man sieht
sie ja nicht richtig, die sind richtig blöd aus, die Genre Beschreibungen sind ja sowas
wie Drama, Movie, Soap und sowas, also die sind ziemlich Müll, vielleicht schaut der
neue Chef auch, ne das glaube ich nicht, also mein aktueller Chef, von dem weiß ich, den
habe ich sogar schon mal im Stream gesehen, im Chat habe ich nichts zu gesagt, aber der
neue nicht, ne ne, glaube ich nicht, dass der Twitch guckt, ich hab's gesehen, ich hab
sogar schon runtergeladen, aber ich hatte heute keine Nerven mehr das ganze zu spielen,
ich gucke mir das morgen an, vielleicht mache ich auch ein Video zu, übrigens Leute, mein
aktuelles Video, ja, das hätte ich gar nicht, was habe ich denn da auf, ach den Fachinformatiker
Plan, mein aktuelles Video, das kommt richtig gut an, ich hab das hochgeladen vorhin, hat
jetzt schon über, die Anzeige ist nicht ganz richtig, hat glaube ich schon mittlerweile
13.000 Aufrufe oder so, aber ich gucke mal kurz rein bei mir, im YouTube Channel, Zack,
äh, bin ich nicht eingeloggt, kann das sein, Alter, ich will mein Profil nicht generaten,
was ist denn das wieder für ein Crap, ich kann mich nicht bei Google einloggen, weil
ich mit einem anderen Account eingeloggt bin und ich jetzt nicht YouTube aufmachen darf,
okay, Sign Out, jetzt YouTube aufmachen, ich gucke mal kurz, aber ich glaube es war irgendwas
um 13.000 Views mittlerweile schon, ah ne, okay, kann ich nicht machen, oder, kann ich
das doch machen, wartet mal, Max FPS, Next, Next, Two Step Authentification, boah ne,
ich bleib jetzt ausgeloggt, ich hab jetzt kein Bock das Handy zu holen, dann nicht, aber
ich glaube es hatte irgendwas um 13.000 Views schon, das ist wirklich gut angekommen und
ich glaube ich hab da auch den Nerv getroffen bei manchen, ich muss aber sagen, ganz im
Endeffekt, was da manche Leute wieder schreiben, ist wie der Streb, haha, ich hab die geilste
Einladung überhaupt, gerade, sehe ich ja gerade auf dem Handy erst, lol, das ist geil, okay,
das muss ich euch erzählen, Moment, ich hab, ich hab gerade eine Einladung bekommen, die
sich nennt, von der Arbeit, Moment, ich muss, ich muss den Service, ich muss den Service
ein bisschen, ein bisschen umbenennen, weil man sonst weiß, äh, um was es geht, weil
in dem Service quasi der Name von meinem Arbeitgeber drin ist, deswegen so ein weiterer Micro, Microservice
oder was auch immer, was sie da haben, zumindest, da steht drinnen, okay, wie nenne ich das
Ding jetzt, okay, ich weiß, wie ich es nenne, also ich hab Einladung bekommen, HTTPS Test
Easy Server, so, in Wirklichkeit heißt das anders und wisst ihr was der Witz ist, also
das klingt jetzt erstmal nicht wild, aber heute Nacht um 23 Uhr wird der Easy Server
live geschaltet, ich weiß nicht, wo der Sinn ist, diesen Service zum ersten Mal morgen
um 11 Uhr zu testen, das hätten sie vielleicht ein bisschen früher machen sollen, oder?
Ich mein ja nur, ich mein ja nur, also wenn der heute Abend 23 Uhr live geschaltet wird,
hätte man den sich vielleicht mal die letzte Woche angucken sollen oder sowas und nicht
erst morgen um 11 Uhr testen, was ist das denn schon wieder für ein rumgefusche, ey man,
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser, nein, nein, ich wollte nicht Steve
Jobs anklingen, Musik leiser, Sekunde, Tests immer nach dem Release, alter die Leute teilweise
bei uns, echter Wahnsinn, wir testen das morgen um 11 Uhr, bin mal gespannt, das war eh wieder
ein typischer Business Stonks, Krempel ohne Scheiß, wir haben ja eigentlich mittlerweile
relativ gut dokumentierte Prozesse, wenn was Neues eingeführt werden soll, Problem ist
nur, die Leute halten sich dann letztendlich nicht dran und das sind die gleichen Leute,
die damals mitgemacht haben beim Einführen dieser Prozesse, zumindest, es gibt laut
unserem Change Prozess quasi ein Umsetzungsdatum, das ist zwingend erforderlich, dass da ein
Umsetzungsdatum drin ist, also sprich, wann geplant ist, wann das ganze live gehen soll
und da steht drin 28.06. und ich hab das dementsprechend auch geplant, ja, ich hab mir gedacht, gut,
ich bau das jetzt mal ein bei uns ins Config Management, dann probieren wir das mal aus
und letzte Woche Freitag, Freitags auch, da muss man sich mal vorstellen, ja, letzte
Woche Freitags huft mich mein Chef an und hat irgendjemand von der Anwendungsentwicklung
in der Leitung und meinte, ja, wie weit wäre das ganze denn, derjenige, der das koordiniert,
der ist ja krank, vielleicht wissen wir was, hab ich gesagt, ja, 28.06., ganz normal,
sobald quasi Config Management mal wieder läuft mit den neuesten Changes, dann ist das
da, dann testen wir das in der Testumgebung, dann ist das so in zwei Wochen oder so, ist
das dann so weit live, dass ihr das ausprobieren könnt und dann meinte, nein, nein, das reicht
nicht, also wie, das reicht nicht, ich denk 28.06., und dann meinte sie, nein, nein, 10.06.,
da denk ich mir auch, wozu haben wir diese Prozesse und Abläufe, wenn sich keine Sau
dran hält, ja, da hab ich jetzt noch irgendwas hingefrickelt, also im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes, ich hab irgendwas hingewurstet, das ist so schlimm, Leute, müsst ihr euch vorstellen,
ich hab auf diesem Server jetzt extra, damit es funktioniert, weil wir, also normalerweise,
dass du intern auf Server zugreifen kannst, ist das so, du musst bei uns über irgendeinen
Loadbalancer, der das dann weiter verteilt, so, nachdem wir allerdings nicht jetzt mal nebenbei
uns da neue Loadbalancer-Config aus dem Ärmel schütteln können, haben wir es jetzt so gemacht,
ich benutze den alten Port, der schon Loadbalanced wird und installiere ein Reverse-Proxy auf
diesem Port, der ist auf das neue Ziel, Reverse-Proxy Loadbalancer, noch mal weiter, also sprich,
der Loadbalancer loadbalancet auf den alten Port, auf dem alten Port ist allerdings gar
nicht mehr das Service, wo das eigentlich rauskommen soll, sondern da läuft jetzt ein
Reverse-Proxy, der das Ganze annimmt und dann auf den eigentlichen Service weiterleitet,
ich sag euch doch, ich bin richtig hingefrickelt und wisst ihr was das beste ist, es ist nicht
etwa so, da hab ich übrigens den hier genommen, den wir auch schon öfters im Stream verwendet
haben, also ich finde Ease of Use und sonst was, das kann ich wirklich wunderbar, vor
allem weil das als einzelnes Go-Binary, ich hatte jetzt nicht die Zeit irgendwie bei uns
ins Repo neue RPM Packages zu packen oder sowas, wisst ihr was ich jetzt gemacht hab,
das ist ernsthaft kein Witz, ich hab jetzt WGET gemacht auf alle Server, also auch auf
produktive Server, WGET gemacht, Caddy runtergeladen, config angelegt, TMUX-Session gestartet und
jetzt läuft unter meinem User in meiner TMUX-Session ein Caddy im Vordergrund, im Terminal, der
produktive Service ist loadbalancet, damit wir keine Loadbalancer Anpassungen brauchen,
damit das bis zum zehnten, sechsten durch ist, also wenn diesen Server irgendjemand neu
startet ist eh vorbei, dann wird dem Leben nicht wieder hochkommen und funktionieren,
also das ist wirklich, aber hey, ich hab's gesagt, ja, ich hab's gesagt und letztendlich
die wollen das, also der Koordinator hat gesagt, ja das, mach das so, sogar der Koordinator,
ich hab's gescreenshotted, ohne Scheiß, ich hab's gescreenshotted, hat mir gesagt,
ja dieser Easy Service, dieser Easy Server, der ist nicht so wichtig und wenn es mal dann
nicht kurz ausruckelt oder so, ist nicht schlimm, ich hab mir diese Aussage extra gescreenshotted
und dass es okay ist, wie ich das gemacht hab, dass man das im Nachgang dann alles fixen
kann und da bin ich, ich war gespannt, was dabei rauskommt jetzt, oh man, der tägliche
Büsse Stonks Enterprise Umfeld Wahnsinn, genau, es darf maximal 3 Millisekunden ruckeln ja,
ich mein, wenn man sich anguckt, was wir teilweise für krasse SLAs bezahlen und es weder brauchen
noch kontrollieren, ob die sogar eingehalten werden, weiß ich nicht, also die schmeißen
gerne, ja gut, es ist eine Bank, die haben genug Geld, ja, die schmeißen gerne Geld
zum Fenster raus, The Code Monkey 82, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub, hast du dir das unterschreiben
lassen?
Ja, ich hab ihn gefragt, den das koordiniert, der hat gesagt, ja, ich hab mir den Screenshot
vorhin gemacht, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand ernsthaft dort argumentieren wird, ich hätte
den Screenshot gefälscht und wenn, und wenn das wirklich einer sagt, dann mach ich wirklich
den Screenshot, und wisst ihr, wenn das einer sagt, dann mute ich mich einfach und spiele
nur noch, ab und geh raus, weil das kann ich mir nicht wirklich vorstellen, dass das einer
behaupten würde, ich hätte den Teams Screenshot gefälscht, wie gehts dem Unraid, das steht
hinter mir im Server Raum und unraidet vor sich hin, es läuft noch nicht alles komplett
drauf, aber es ist an und surft und macht das wofür es da ist, The Most Epic GitHub Pull
Request of All Time, das hab ich gesehen, das ist irgendein Typ, der Epic Games GitHub
für die Unreal Engine was reingepackt hat und hat 250.000 Leute angeschrieben, ausversehen,
was ich nicht gut fand ist, wie Hass erfüllt teilweise die Antworten der Leute da waren,
ich mein, ganz im Ernst, vielleicht ist es einfach jemand, der keinen Plan hat, was er
gemacht hat, oder 54.000, da haben sich die Leute wieder aufgespielt, 50 Benachrichtigungen
kriegst du, 51 Benachrichtigungen, Leute die eh wenig Benachrichtigungen kriegen verkraften
es trotzdem, ich seh das nicht so, wenn ich mir überlege, ich hab's auf der Arbeit mittlerweile
so gemacht, meine E-Mail Inbox, die wird quasi gar nicht mehr direkt benutzt, in der bleibt
alles drin, ich guck in meine Inbox auch nicht mehr rein, ich hab einen Filter, der geht,
alles was direkt an mich geht, oder an mich im CC, geht in einen Ordner an mich, und dann
hab ich noch was, was an den Teamverteiler geht, das geht in einen Ordner Team, der Rest
bleibt ungelesen in der Inbox, und es ist schon öfters mal vorgekommen, dass die Leute mich
fragen, Max, was ist denn los, hast du das nicht gesehen, dann muss ich sagen, ups, übersehen,
weil, ich blick sonst nicht mehr durch, das ist so, ja, ja, du musst in der Epic Github
Gruppe beitreten, wenn du bei Unreal irgendwie in die Docs oder in den Source Code gucken
willst, glaube, was auch immer, Kündigung übersehen, deswegen müssen Kündigungen
immer schriftlich zugestellt werden, und nicht per Mail, aber ja, ich mein, wenn man
die Kündigung übersehen könnte, wäre es ja easy, dann könnte man einfach immer sagen,
was, na, das hab ich nicht gesehen, jetzt müssen wir leider noch mal drei Monate warten,
das ist richtig bescheuert gemacht, Serious Max, hast du recht, schon auf, ja, ich hab
auf die neuste Version geupgraded, warum, achso, nee, aber die allerneueste, jetzt
war die neuste Major Version, auf die hab ich schon geupgraded, ja, gut, Leute, heute,
ich hab gestern so viel geschwätzt hier im Stream, ich hab gar kein großartiges Schwätzmaterial
mehr, wir machen morgen, kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen, morgen machen wir entweder den
noch ein bisschen weiter am EPG-Champ, ich bin mir da gar nicht wirklich sicher, was
wir von beiden machen, also entweder, also wir haben drei Sachen zur Auswahl morgen,
wir könnten theoretisch eine Abstimmung machen, was haltet ihr davon, wir könnten eine Abstimmung
machen, was wir morgen im Stream machen, und zwar, wir müssen noch ein paar Sachen am
EPG-Champ machen, also sprich, das ist dann im Endeffekt.NET und JavaScript programmieren,
nein, Diablo spielen wir nicht, das geb ich mir nicht weiter, also das ist die erste Auswahl,
wir könnten Svelte, JavaScript, C-Sharp, ASP.NET Core programmieren, EPG-Champ, wir könnten,
also alles Sachen, die wir noch machen müssen, das nächste ist, wir machen den Zabbix weiter,
oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, der Zabbix, wir machen den Zabbix weiter, weil es gibt
noch ein paar Sachen, die ich ausprobieren will, unter anderem, meine Internetverbindung
überwachen, also quasi im Hintergrund regelmäßig mal einen Speedcheck machen, dass ich mir
einen schönen Graph malen kann, wie gut ist denn Vodafone, auch wenn man nicht gerade aktiv
nachguckt, und noch Kisten bei mir hinzufügen, die ich hier im Haus habe, gucke wie man Access
Points ordentlich überwacht, es kommt noch mehr Zabbix, ja, wie gesagt, steht zur Auswahl,
danke für deinen Zabb, also Zabbix weiter machen, steht zur Auswahl, und das dritte
ist, wir machen gleich ne Umfrage, irgendeiner der Mods, falls einer da ist, macht gleich
ne Umfrage, wenn ich erklärt hab, was es alles gibt, und das dritte ist Rust WebAssembly,
das will ich mir lange Zeit schon mal angucken, aber ich hab bisher noch nicht so wirklich
den Aufhänger gefunden, warum ich das mal machen will, also mir schwebt ja vor, mir
schwebt ja vor folgendes, ich würde gerne FFM-Pack im Browser verwenden, und zwar über
WebAssembly, warum Rust, wir könnten auch C++ machen, da ist mir Rust aber lieber, also
ich glaube Rust ist für WebAssembly ganz cool, gerade auch in Kombination mit Packages,
die es dafür schon gibt, und es gibt viele gute Tutorials, und es muss wohl relativ einfach
sein, sowohl Bindings zu erstellen, dass man das ganze von JavaScript keulen kann, es gibt
wohl schon viele fertige Packages, auch die Tools, muss das quasi schon out of the box
alles integriert sein, ja, du kannst sogar dort net WebAssembly machen, ich weiß, das
letzte Mal war das aber ziemlicher Paints-Champ, ich hoffe, dass das besser wird mit ihrer
neuen Ahead of Time-Kompilation, die ja noch bisschen eklig ist, ja, ähm, übrigens, das
sage ich euch auch gleich dazu, ihr kennt mich, wenn ich morgen, also mal angenommen, es gewinnt
jetzt Zappix oder so mit 100 Stimmen, ich behalte mir vor, wenn ich morgen gar keinen
Bock drauf hab, vielleicht was anderes zu machen, oder auch gar nicht zu streamen, aber
ich denke, ich halte mich dran, ja, wir machen alle drei Sachen, wir machen alle drei Sachen,
aber es ist ja nur die Frage, was wir morgen machen wollen, ok, es sieht nach Rust WebAssembly
aus, oh, das wird Big Brain werden, gucken, ob wir irgendwie FFmpeg zum Laufen bekommen,
und dann, wie man den ganzen Krempel aufrufen kann aus JavaScript, wann, ja, irgendwann
abends wieder, wahrscheinlich nicht so spät wie heute, ich denke mal, also, morgen arbeite
ich 15.30, 16 Uhr, wahrscheinlich 15.30, und dann gehe ich erst mal 1,5, 2, eher 2
Stunden wandern, oder laufen, besser gesagt, muss mich ja bewegen, ich muss ja noch weiter
P-Pro-Fat abnehmen, es klappt aktuell einfach zu gut, das jetzt schleifen zu lassen, und
danach können wir eigentlich anfangen, also, Rust WebAssembly, würde ich sagen, hat gewonnen,
es sei denn, es kommt jetzt in der letzten Sekunde noch der Vote-Bot, ok, ich schreibe
mir das mal auf, oh, ich wollte das eigentlich kopieren, aber das ist verboten, wie es aussieht,
ah nee, ich hab's noch reincopy pasted, ja, weil ich hab euch ja gezeigt, wie gut das
ganze läuft, denn, ich bin jetzt von 108,5 runter auf 97,6, also das sind quasi, sagen
wir mal, 11 Kilo, in ungefähr, also seit Ende Februar, also seit so dreieinhalb Monaten
ungefähr, also, ich hoffe, ich hab eigentlich kein richtiges Ziel, nur eins, und zwar, ich
hoffe, ich krieg irgendwann vielleicht bis Ende des Jahres vielleicht was um 90 hin,
das würde mir aber schon komplett reichen erst mal, weil dann bin ich quasi wieder
so schwer wie seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr, ja, Sternleak, ja, guckt mal Leute, warte ich
ja noch drauf, dass irgendjemand das jetzt durch den AI-Algorithmus hoch lädt und das
dann CSI-mäßig ranzoomt und sagt, hier, Max Face Leak, weil die Spiegelung von hier
ist die Spiegelung, die in die Wand geht und dann über die Kachel das Face aufgelöst,
ja, also, ja, man erkennt, dass ich eine, dass ich Haare hab, man erkennt auch, dass
ich ein Gesicht habe und eine Stirn, aber ich glaube, das wars im Großen und Ganzen,
was man so erkennt, ok, dass ich auch, dass ich, dass ich rechts ein Auge hab, erkennt
man auch noch, wenn man viel, viel rein interpretiert, aber ich glaube, davon sind die meisten Leute
ausgegangen, dass ich einen Kopf habe mit Augen, ihr wisst ja, eine Million Subscriber
auf Face Reveal, was eh nicht passieren wird, deswegen bin ich safe, ich hab mich so oft
schon geleakt, es gab sogar schon Videos, wo man mich drin gesehen hat, es hat bloß
keiner gecheckt, dass ich das war, es ist auch nicht wild, also ganz im Ernst, es ist
gar nicht so sehr, dass mich das großartig stören würde jetzt, wenn ich da irgendwo
mal wirklich zu erkennen bin, ich will halt bloß nicht quasi für jeden offensichtlich
präsent sein im Video, weil ich hab keine Lust drauf, ihr wisst, ich mag in der Regel
keine Leute, die mir auf der Straße so über den Weg laufen und Leute, die mich ansprechen
und nerven noch weniger und ich hab einfach keinen Bock irgendwie angesprochen werden
unterwegs von Leuten, die mich vor YouTube kennen, ich hab das gesehen schon beim Friseur
damals und das ist bei weitem nicht so krass, wie das heute ist und wir hatten damals auch
bei weitem nicht so viele Subscriptions, wie nervig das ist und ich hab keinen Bock drauf,
dass mich Leute auf der Straße erkennen und sagen, ah Max guck mal und was auch immer,
im Zweifelsfall muss ich ja noch Bilder machen mit denen oder sowas, ne ne ne ne, da fangen
wir jetzt gar nicht mit an, ja, ach stimmt, es gab ja einen neuen Official Dark Water
Level Gameplay, ok komm, wir sind mal nicht so, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was gerade,
der Chat, Leute, ich hab ja sogar gesehen, ihr habt den ganzen Krempel auch noch geklippt
das letzte Mal, das war ja klar, dass ich da wieder alle komplett drauf stürze, wir
können uns tatsächlich mal das angucken, weil ich bin auf zweierlei Arten gespannt
auf Modern Warfare 2, ich bin auf die erste Art gespannt, ob sich das bewahrheitet, was
ich denke, nämlich, dass das eine weitere kreative Bankrotterklärung ist, was Call
of Duty angeht, ich fand den Reboot von Modern Warfare schon bescheuert, der Erfolg gibt
ihnen insofern recht, ich mein, gerade mit ihrem, dass dieses Warzone, könnte man fast
schon Spinoff nennen mittlerweile, wie sich das entwickelt, hat natürlich wahnsinnig
viel Geld gemacht für die, die Bewertungen sehen schon ziemlich gut aus, ja, und das
fanden tatsächlich auch viele Leute richtig gut, ich muss sagen, ich erkenne an, dass
Modern Warfare für Call of Duty tatsächlich mal ein bisschen Fortschritt bedeutet hat,
also auch grafisch, die ganze Skill-based Matchmaking-Geschichte, ja, da sag ich jetzt
nichts zu, aber das Remaster oder das Re-Release oder das Re-Boot, muss man jetzt sagen, jetzt
noch weiter, ich mein, ernsthaft, ich war live dabei, mit Call of Fear, mit Modern Warfare
2, mit Modern Warfare, ich hab die originale Modern Warfare Trilogie durch, ich war da
live dabei, also für mich ist es einfach nur ideenloser Aufguss, das kann man jetzt
über Call of Duty generell sagen, aber gerade mit Modern Warfare finde ich, das ist halt
so ein Ding, das sagt mir einfach nur Leute, wir sind nicht mehr in der Lage, uns was anderes
auszudenken und wir müssen jetzt halt maximal Kohle machen, indem wir eben die Nostalgie-Leute
ansprechen und zusätzlich noch, ich weiß es nicht, es wirkt einfach so unkreativ und
so gelangweilt nur noch, gerade dass man das jetzt fortsetzt, aber das heißt nicht, dass
es irgendwie jetzt übertrieben schlecht sein muss, ich weiß, dass das letzte Mal, der
Ejax ist auch da, ich weiß, dem Ejax hat das wunderbar gefallen, Modern Warfare geradezu
zu Release, so, gucken wir uns mal an, also, zeig mal her, ist das ein, wie nennt man das,
ein reimagining der Schiffsmission, plus auf ner Ölbohrplattform jetzt, ey, der Typ hört
sich aus wie einer von Battle, der hört sich doch voll an wie einer von Battlefield Friends,
hör doch, den tut man an, der hört sich an wie Battlefield Friends, oh, die sind aber
ganz schön hart am Monka Stian, oder, ist das, also Captain Price hab ich jetzt noch
nicht gesehen, wo hab ich eigentlich mein Monka Stian im Auto, das ist weg, wo ist mein
Monka Stian, da, der Typ hört sich wirklich an wie einer von Battlefield Friends, ich
mach absichtlich ein bisschen leise, weil die Call of Duty Trailer gleich schreien die
wie verrückt rum und es explodiert Zeug, warum haben die zwei keinen Helm an, das ist ganz
einfach, das ist wie in nem Film, das soll cool aussehen, dass man die Gesichter der
Charakter sieht, niemand würde in sowas ohne Helm gehen, soll das Saub sein, wegen dem
Haarschnitt, nee, oder, ist das Saub, soll das Saub sein, ich mein vom Haarschnitt her
wirds passen, wollen die uns ernsthaft versehen, die sehen die nicht, das ist Saub, das ist
wirklich Saub, habt ihr das gerade gehört, ich muss, ich bin da wirklich sehr zwiegisch,
weil auf der einen Seite finde ich das, als jemand der Call of Duty 4 gut fand, ich hab
auch gerne MW2 gesuchtet, cool, dass Saub wieder am Start ist, aber es ist, und das
muss man einfach trotz, trotz diesem Wiedererkennung, ich würd sagen, es ist einfach komplette
kreative Bankrotterklärung, jetzt noch mal die ganze Geschichte mit Saub und Price,
ich mein ernsthaft, wir habens doch schon komplett durch, da fühlt sich gar nicht so
übel aus, ist das vielleicht auf Xbox, nee, sieht doch ganz in Ordnung aus, ja wir machen
das, okay das ist nur noch 15 Call of Duty Kost aktuell, ich mein ernsthaft niemand
spielt das so, man sprintet da durch, wie sie da immer rumschleichen,
Weltmodus aktiviert, immer schön den Boden abamen, genau, eigentlich, Leute ernsthaft,
eigentlich hätten wir schon direkt erraten können, dass dieser Typ jetzt stirbt, weil
das der einzige Character ist mit Helm auf, das ist quasi Austauschbarer Statist, das
Spiel sieht nicht besser aus als MW 2019, nee, das hätte ich jetzt aber auch nicht
erwartet, das wird doch wie bei Call of Duty immer so sein, jetzt der letzte große Sprung
für Call of Duty war mit Modern Warfare 2019, wo man sich auch mal wirklich was am Unterbau
getan hat, das wird jetzt für die nächsten 10 Jahre bis zum nächsten Modern Warfare
Reboot wird das so bleiben, Modern Warfare 1 hat damals quasi die Grafik ziemlich modernisiert,
das war damals auf quasi von der Grafik her bei den Leuten im Kopf nicht viel schlechter
als Crysis, was blödsinnig ist, aber viele Leute haben damals beides als super krass
toll angesehen und jetzt hat es halt bis zum Modern Warfare Reboot gebraucht, bis das Spiel
wieder ordentlich aussieht und jetzt brauchen wir wahrscheinlich das nächste Modern Warfare
Reboot, also so ungefähr 2030 dann, dann wird die Grafik wieder aktualisiert, also
8 Jahre kann man jetzt schon noch mit der alten Grafik von 2019 leben, ich meine Call
of Duty hat davor auch 10 Jahre mit der Grafik von Modern Warfare 4, äh Call of Duty 4 gelebt,
warum haben die eigentlich, das war eine bescheuerte Frage, warum haben die eigentlich die Stun
Granate beziehungsweise das Flashbang so geworfen und so geguckt, dass sie es selbst abbekommen
haben, ich meine ist das nicht, ist das nicht irgendwie ziemlich pepega, oder, also mein
ja nur, aber auf so Sachen muss man sich ja bei besten Willen keine Gedanken machen,
es sieht sehr nach ziemlich Standard Call of Duty Kost aus, also das könnte quasi auch
exakt so im originalen Modern Warfare gewesen sein, es sieht ein bisschen besser aus, ok
ich predict, ich predicte mal was, was jetzt noch passiert, mal gucken, mal gucken ob ich
recht hab, ich predicte gleich kommt ein Chopper und dann wird der Chopper mit dem RPG abgeschossen,
wo auch immer der Heli herkommt, also vom Aufbau her soll das glaube ich wirklich absichtlich
ein bisschen an das Schiffslevel erinnern aus Call of Duty 4, oder mit richtig reif mit
Degas, also ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig, dass diese Station am Ende in die Luft fliegt
und untergeht oder man gerade rechtzeitig abgeholt wird wenn es explodiert oder so, das ist das
klar, aber ich predicte immer noch dass gleich ein Chopper kommt der abgeschossen werden
muss, ah ja, die rote Container selbstverständlich was sonst, gleich Klassiker, ihr habt bestimmt
bei euch auch im Flur rote Container rumstehen die in die Luft fliegen wenn man drauf schießt,
wer hat's ne Cringe wer's nicht hat, der weiß überhaupt nicht ob clear ist, wisst ihr was
mich das ein bisschen erinnert, kennt noch jemand dieses Back Ops Mission aus Modern
Warfare 2 mit dieser Insel, wo man mit dieser Ölplattform oder was das war, das könnte
sogar eine der letzten Missionen gewesen sein, die war gar nicht so leicht, wo dann irgendwie
noch zig Juggernauts gekommen sind und sowas, es gab so ne Back Ops Mission in MW2 auf so
ne Insel, also wenn die jetzt wieder ne Nuke finden wie in MW4, wie in CoD 4, also ich
hoffe nicht, es wäre möglich exakt wieder der gleiche Krämpel.
Okay, es ist typisches Call of Duty Kram, okay, die übliche bisschen Knockout, jetzt
kommt gleich Price um die Ecke und hilft einem hoch oder sowas, oh nein man kann diesmal
selbst aufstehen, ach das ist ja gar nicht Price, ja das ist jetzt, ich sag euch das
ist absichtlich so gemacht, dass die Leute sich erinnert fühlen an die Schiffsmission
von Call of Duty 4, das wird bestimmt auch ne Multiplayer Map, sag mal was muss man eigentlich
machen damit man Trailer Vorspieler werden darf, ja das ist original MW1 hier, also nicht
original, aber es ist absichtlich quasi gemacht in der gleichen Art und Weise, Wedgework
ist die Map, ja genau, Ayabila, Ayabila, Tango Sucker, da fehlen die realistischen
Sounds ja, die realistischen Sprüche, Pepega Amp braucht man ja, Bambi, okay ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob ich das jetzt auf der einen Seite, ne eigentlich finde ich es nicht cool,
das ist nicht nur dran orientiert, ich mein das ist mehr oder weniger das Level aus MW1,
aus MW1, dem nicht Reboot, dem Original, es kam normalerweise jetzt der Heli, normalerweise
kam jetzt der Heli, aber die sind ja nicht im Heli gelandet, ah Door Breach, Door Breach,
ne ich preordere definitiv nicht now, tja, es sieht aus als hat man Call of Duty 4 nochmal
reverwurstet, das könnte allerdings witzigerweise, auch wenn ich jetzt ein paar mal gesagt habe,
ich finde das Kran von der Kran komplett für die Tonne, aber das könnte tatsächlich dazu
führen, dass ich das spiele, einfach weil ich wissen will was sie draus gemacht haben,
hat es erfolgreich gebadet, sie müssten nur Content bringen ohne Cringe Voice Lines,
die müssten überhaupt Content bringen, dann sind sie schon besser als Battlefield 2042,
es wäre elegant eingeführt.
Guck ich so gut finde ich gibt ab und zu mal die ein oder anderen ganz leisten videos aber
also ich sehe für mich jetzt da nicht den grund warum ich mir das öfters angucken sollte also
ist irgendwie was dabei wo ich sagen mit oder habe ich jetzt was gelernt oder habe ich da was
gesehen das war mir so noch nicht klar oder irgendwie oder das war es ist selten eins muss man sagen also
ja doch eine sache halte ich von den uns techtaps er ist der meister der abo sellout nicht der abo
sellout der shop sellout überleitung also das können die wirklich gut die machen ja mittlerweile
drei mal sellout in so einem video die machen entweder sponsor sellout am anfang sponsor
sellout am ende eigener shop sonst was noch sehr laut also das haben die wirklich wahnsinnig
drauf den sellout haben die perfektioniert zumal die haben die ja schon mal remastered neu verkauft
ich bin mal gespannt vielleicht ich mein was man ja auch machen könnte ist man könnte also ich sag
jetzt mal was ich gehe nicht davon aus dass ich es machen aber man könnte die leute auch richtig
krass debaten überlegt euch mal erste mission du bist mit saub auf dem schiff und du denkst dir so
fuck ich weiß was kommt und dann stirbt saub einfach so instant durch irgendwie so ein random
npc und es passiert was ganz anderes als man erwartet hätte oder was auch immer so was in
der richtung aber ich glaube nicht dass sie das machen werden ja das das quasi alter alternate
reality irgendwie sowas ich glaube es aber nicht naja warum nicht es muss ja nicht nur durch den
random npc sein es könnte ja tatsächlich auch durch den bösewicht sein und am ende dann was
auch immer ich meine sie können ja nicht wirklich call of duty 4 noch mal neu bei was sage ich sie
können nicht wirklich doch das können sie und das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch sie werden
wahrscheinlich call of duty 4 bringen mit leichter abwandlung und nostalgie abgreifen ja naja mal
gucken bin gespannt habt ihr gesehen wann release date war ich will nicht meine meine
waage gucken war dann noch mal ok ich krieg es nicht mehr geöffnet was ist denn hier los
wann war noch mal release date sekunde achso ich finde noch nicht mal mehr was wir gerade
geguckt haben ok ich kann jetzt in die history gucken aber scheiß drauf was ist denn release
date bestimmt november wie immer wahrscheinlich oder modern warfare 2 release date kommt
wahrscheinlich bei google ja 2009 release steht fest ok ok oktober sind wir ein bisschen früher
28 oktober ist ja nicht so dass sie angst vor der battlefield konkurrenz haben müssen
da ist ja nicht viel zu holen ich werde morgen in paar runden zero hour spielen vielleicht den
stream mal gucken und um festzustellen dass es halt nichts gibt im endeffekt die haben
bestimmt für der alte reload animation und sowas auch importiert ok wollen wir uns kommen
wir lassen uns noch eine runde von level cap jebaiten battlefield 2042 ist in abandon ship
mode sagt wer tom henderson oder wer ganz im ernst selbst wenn das also mich würde es
wundern wenn es nicht so wäre ich dachte schon die ganze zeit dass sie da eigentlich nichts
machen dass sie da ein paar leute sitzen haben die das absolut mindeste liefern ich krieg
mein eigenes video empfohlen das ist gut das muss ich jetzt auch anklicken für die für
die für die view time ja das ist im hintergrund mal laufen die das absolut mindeste wie findet
ihr das thumbnail ich finde das ist eigentlich ganz gut gelungen das sieht so aus als möchte
man es anklicken ja das war wie gesagt dass da einfach noch ein paar hansel sitzen bei
da ist das absolut mindeste liefern was sein muss und dann wird es eingestellt ja gucken
wir kommen wir lassen uns noch mal eine runde level cap jebaiten
2042 ist mehr unabhängig als jemals call of duty modern warfare wirklich 2 gameplay
wurde entdeckt die diablo immortal spieler sind ausgerichtet und viel mehr outrage ist
ja heutzutage schon standard also sag mir mal irgendwann gab es irgendwie einen tag in
den letzten zehn jahren über wo nicht irgendwas besonders outrage outrage ing war egal was
es war es war jeden tag irgendwas super krasse outrage
ist das eigentlich jetzt schon live zero hour ja gell ach das ist auch von gestern
ja es ist doch genau das was ich sag es ist doch genau das was ich gesagt habe die machen
das mindeste und dann war es das fertig
best it can be and they don't have an end date for this particular game however today
industry insider jeff grubb claimed that 2042 is being worked on by a skeleton crew whose
priority ich finde das geil wie jetzt wie du irgendwelche krassen lika brauche so dass
die leute auf diese idee überhaupt erst kommen ja wie gesagt ich sag schon mehr oder weniger
seit dem release was passiert wird es ist einfach nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie die
krassen prophetischen voraussehungskünste hätte oder so aber es ist doch klar es ist
doch offensichtlich es würde eher wundern wenn das anders gewesen wäre und da müsste
Da müssen jetzt irgendwelche tollen Insider kommen, die das dann sagen, auch übrigens Leute, das ist so und so.
Und ich so, was? Wirklich? Na, da hätten wir jetzt ja gar nicht mitrechnen können.
Content Obligations as quickly and cheaply as possible, while the studio...
Wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass Diablo Immortal im App Store mit 4,6 bewertet ist?
Weiß ich nicht, aber entweder kriegst du kostenloses Gier für eine Bewertung.
Das ist ja auch gängige Praxis bei Mobile Games. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das mittlerweile...
...noch erlaubt ist.
Oder es ist halt genau die richtige Zielgruppe dafür, nämlich Mobile Gamer.
Und ich hab heute bei Trimax, ich gucke normalerweise nie Trimax, aber es wurde mir empfohlen, Diablo Immortal.
Ich hab in einem Video bei Trimax geguckt, kurz irgendwas, wir cashen richtig rein in Diablo Immortal.
Und die Leute haben das Game mega abgefeiert in den Kommentaren.
Und auch mit so Dingern wie, ich verstehe gar nicht, warum sich hier alle aufregen über Pay2Win.
Du musst doch überhaupt nichts ausgeben und haha, ich habe einen riesen Spaß mit diesem Game.
So viel Spaß hatte ich schon lange mit keinem Spiel mehr.
Also, vielleicht trifft es auch gerade den Nerv von vielen.
Ich glaube, dass ihr das schaffen könnt. Natürlich, natürlich. Blizzard wird garantiert das komplette...
...wobei Blizzard, es ist ja im Prinzip Blizzard plus ein China-Chinesen-Hersteller.
Natürlich, Blizzard wird das ganz bestimmt überarbeiten und es zu einem viel besseren Game ohne Pay2Win machen.
Ja, Kappa, ganz sicherlich.
Wir haben den Modern Warfare 2 Trailer gerade geguckt, ja.
Das ist ja auch nichts Neues.
Ja, aber sag mal mal so, das ist ja normal.
Also, du hast bei größeren Spielen, vor allem die halt auch in einem strafferen Release-Zyklus erscheinen.
Muss jetzt nicht gleich so krass wie Call of Duty sein.
Wenn das eine Game fertig ist, selbstverständlich wird sich dann um das neue Game gekümmert.
Ja, was denn sonst? Das entwickelt sich nicht von alleine.
Wobei man könnte vielleicht argumentieren, wenn irgendeine advanced AI-Battlefield entwickelt hätte,
der Austeilen der alten Battlefields, dann wäre es besser geworden als Battlefield 2042.
Aber noch haben die da ein eigenes Entwicklerteam für und selbstverständlich arbeiten die an einem neuen Game,
wenn das aktuelle Game fertig ist.
Was nicht zwangsläufig heißt, dass das alte komplett auf Sparflamme laufen muss, ja.
Du kannst ja durchaus Leute der Sache zuteilen oder auch andere Leute hinsetzen.
Du brauchst ja da nicht unbedingt jetzt deine fiveheadigsten Frostbite-Entwickler für das alte Game, ja.
Aber ansonsten wundert das überhaupt nicht.
Was ist das überhaupt für eine Auflösung da im Hintergrund? Das war ja...
Ach, jetzt ist die Auflösung auf einmal gut.
Na dann.
Immortal Crash beim Start.
Geht ja gut los.
Unshackled.
Ihr habt euch die Handschellen selbst angelegt, DICE.
Es war eure freie Wahl. Ihr habt das Game designt.
Es ist doch nicht so, als hätten die Spieler gesagt,
DICE, ihr müsst 128 Spieler machen, sonst gibt es Haue.
DICE hat gesagt wir machen 128 Spieler.
Und das ist das geilste seit geschnitten Brot.
Und alle haben gesagt, bin mir nicht so sicher, ob 128 Spieler eine gute Idee ist.
Und jetzt tun sie es so herunter und wir haben uns uns anschackled von 128 Spieler.
Also ernsthaft jetzt.
And that all new content will be designed to offer the most fun experience possible.
However, that doesn't mean future content won't support 128 players.
A DICE community manager responded to the articles by saying there is no intention to drop 128
player support from future content.
Ja, und wir wissen natürlich auch, das was DICE sagt, da ist ja Verlass drauf.
Stabs have also clarified that future maps are being developed with lessons learned from
the launch maps.
Battlefield 2042 wurde angeblich entwickelt mit lessons learned.
Ein love letter to the community is part leute.
Oh man, dieses Gespätze, ich dreh irgendwann echt noch am Rad.
Ich kanns mir einfach nicht mehr anmelden.
Ich hör vielleicht ist die neue map wirklich gut.
Die Option müssen wir uns mal offen halten.
Aber selbst wenn die neue map wirklich gut ist, das Spiel hat kein Content, dann hast
du eine neue map.
Okay, die map spiele ich vielleicht mal 2, 3, wenns hoch kommt ne Woche, immer mal wieder
und dann hab ich keinen Bock mehr, weil immer die gleiche map den ganzen Tag, oder was
heißt den ganzen Tag, den ganzen Spiel, dann will ja auch keiner machen.
Wo ist denn eigentlich mal ordentlich neuer Content für Portal?
Man könnte so viele Sachen dort importieren aus alten Battlefields, aber man will nicht.
Und das ist das, was ich die ganze Zeit sage, man hat das Spiel mehr oder weniger seit diesem
verschissenen Release und man weiß, dass sich das nicht mehr erholen wird.
Die sind ja auch nicht blöd dort, die haben ja auch Leute, die das analysieren, hat man
das komplett auf Sparflamme laufen, man liefert das mindestens, was man muss, damit man nicht
verklagt wird und fertig.
Areas for different kinds of action and no more wide open barren spaces.
What's your take on all of this info?
The extremely slow progress on 2042's development seems to indicate that it would have a very
small crew working on the game.
Do you think 2042 is going to get the plug pulled as soon as year one content wraps up?
Let us know in the comments.
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 gameplay and info has been revealed.
Activision released a trailer showcasing in-game footage of the single player campaign.
It includes familiar faces like Ghost, Soap and Captain Price.
They get into the usual sequence of globetrotting action showcasing the return of night vision
combat, modern weapons and a new threat to the world.
Visually, the trailer looks very impressive, but it's a heavy mix of cinematics and in-engine
footage, so it's tough to say what it'll actually look like in-game.
That said, if you think 2019's Modern Warfare looks good, Modern Warfare 2 is a clear continuation
of those visuals.
As for actual info about what you can expect from multiplayer, Gunsmith is returning from
2019's Modern Warfare.
It's been upgraded and expanded to give you fine-tune control over each attachment.
And Ghost hat diesmal ernsthafte Maske auf anstatt Lappen über dem Gesicht oder wie?
Warum sollte einer eine Maske aufziehen?
Der originale Ghost hatte einen Lappen über dem Gesicht.
Das ist das was man auch erwarten würde wenn man überhaupt was überm Gesicht hat.
Aber zieht doch keiner ne Maske auf.
It's been upgraded and expanded to give you fine-tune control over each attachment.
Als Beispiel, anstatt nur eine Selektion von Barrels zu wählen, kannst du jede Barreloption mit einem Silencer auswählen, um es schwerer oder leichter zu machen.
Jedes Ende des Spektrums hat seine eigenen Pro und Cons.
Waffenaufgaben und Unlockungen werden auch von Klasse gewonnen, als der gesamte Niveau.
Also, wenn du mit SMGs viel spielst, kannst du mehr SMG-Stuff auswählen.
Einige Beteiligungen sind universal, andere sind einzigartig für bestimmte Waffen.
Wenn du eine neue Waffe auswählen kannst, hast du die Chance, ein paar grundlegende Beteiligungen bereits auswählen zu können.
Wenn es um die Warzone geht, wird die Version von Warzone 1 und Modern Warfare 2 komplett einzigartig auswählen.
Das bedeutet, dass keine von deinen Unlockungen oder Kosmetiken über die Niveau geht.
Waffenaufgaben und Unlockungen werden auch von Klasse gewonnen.